wenn euch das video gefällt und ihr
wieder mehr mit ihm sehen wollt dann
lasst einfach mal daumen nach unten
dann müssen noch bescheid und viel spaß
und ist congstar willkommen beim ein
video ich habe meinen bruder mal wieder
mit dabei
habt ihr mir ganz aufgeschrieben und ja
wir machen heute ein video zusammen wie
heißt es und zwar nennt sich das tricks
seine geschwister zu fahren
genau also einfach so wie man halt so
wenn eure schwester oder urlaub ich mal
wieder auf den sack geht passiert dann
halt so machen können deswegen zeigt
dass auf jeden fall ab ja wir wollen gar
nicht lange lagern und ich bin einfach
sagen oder wir würden sagen los geht und
ich würde sagen gefangen mit trick
nummer 1 an
fangen wir erst mal ganz locker an und
verbraucht ihr für diesen trick einfach
so klarsichtfolie oder irgendwie sowas
ich hatte das leider ich zuhause
deswegen hab ich so typen genommen aber
ich simuliere das einfach mal und zwar
stellt wir das einfach so über euren
klodeckel weil wenn man wirklich die
richtige klarsichtfolie hat dann sieht
man das überhaupt nicht und dann geht
halt euer bruder oder eine schwester
aufs klo und ihr wisst was passiert aber
passt wirklich auch dass eure eltern
nicht zu hause sind oder dass sie halt
nicht dann auf toilette gehen weil das
war ein bisschen scheiße trick nummer 26
patrik wenn euch euer wurde um eure
schwester mal wieder so richtig auf den
sack geht macht ihr einfach folgendes
und sage euch gibt's ja wahrscheinlich
so ich sage jetzt eine um halb eins
mittagessen und um halb sieben
abendessen angenommen das ist jetzt ein
viertel nach sechs dann macht ihr
einfach so auf dem ihr euer bruder oder
schwester toben oder
unten in bad belzig wo die bohnen berlin
mehr leben ja essen ist fertig ja ich
komme es gibt da noch gar kein essen
verarscht trick nummer drei für den
nächsten trick braucht ihr einfach nur
erbsen ein glas und ganz normales
leitungswasser einfach die erbsen
aufmacht ich habe keine ahnung ob das
was das denn also ihr braucht einfach
diese nicht mehr sondern erbsen daraus
hat er nicht auf dieses glas würde uns
der garant von mit erbsen aber was bitte
auf das ihr euch dabei nicht schneidet
weil das ist mir passiert und dann füllt
ihr das ganze am besten ohne blut sowie
an meinem hätten sich darum jetzt mit
etwas wasser und der nächste schritt
kommt jetzt gleich wenn ich mich
verarztet hat ja dann geht ihr mit
diesen erbsen in das zimmer von einem
bruder oder einer schwester und
platziert das so ganz unauffällig hinter
irgendwelchen büchern einfach ja dass
man das halt am besten nicht zieht und
nach ein paar stunden dann saugen sich
diese erst mit diesem wasser voll und
dann fängt das so ganz leise an zu
proben und dann fragst du natürlich eure
schwester oder bruder hubert ist das
team jetzt und kann nicht schlafen trick
nummer vier den nächsten krieg wenn wir
eigentlich ganz einfach so jetzt hier so
simulieren und zwar das geht aber auch
wirklich nur wenn euer bruder oder einer
schwester jünger ist so zehn oder elf
einer glauben die das und zwar sieht das
folgendermaßen aus ich muss dir was
sagen ich bin schwul und das ist
eigentlich so erblich verankert das
heißt du bist wahrscheinlich auch schwul
nächste tumor und längst nicht so wir
haben irgendwie schwul oder so auf jeden
fall trick nummer fünf leute und wenn
euer bruder oder eine schwester so was
das internet angeht eurer meinung nach
das schon wieder viel zu lange vor sitzt
dann macht ihr einfach folgendes und
geht zu hören wlan router oder zu einer
ladebuchse war fleißig und zieht einfach
ganz locker lässig den stecker raus und
spielen
sekunden später wird sich dann irgendwer
oder von irgendwo kommt dann wenn
beschreibt übung fürs internet weg ganz
einfach ja heute so viel erstmal dazu
wenn es euch gefallen hat wie gesagt
gebt einfach noch nach oben dann wisst
ihr bescheid ihr könnt ja mal sein
install um abschreckung ist ja
eingebildet wenn du dich dann vernommen
und dann finden wir das auch mein
instagram step war das könnte natürlich
auch gerne abcheck oder mich da ende
napoli nicht vergessen und ist jetzt
oberwasser oben links jetzt weiter mit
meinem letzten video das war es was
mädchen beim date falsch man checkt das
auf jeden fall ab wir sehen uns mittwoch
wieder haut rein und ciao ciao